hey martin what you doing oh hi dustin
i like reading articles about serverless
on hacker news
but i don't have time to check the
website every day
i found an api to give me the latest
articles and i've heard about scheduled
cron jobs
but i don't know how to combine them
you know that sounds like it might be a
good job for a cloud scheduler
and we can use that with python in the
cloud
yep let me tell you more
[Music]
python is often called a glue language
because it's a powerful tool for easily
combining multiple different systems
part of this is because python has great
client library support
which lets you interact with lots of
apis products and services
from the comfort of python but it
doesn't just end with the cloud
python is useful for combining just
about anything with anything else
so what are you trying to glue together
martin well
i found this hacker news api which gives
me the current
top posts i wanted to email me whenever
there's a new post about
serverless so i never miss an
interesting article
i think we could easily do this with
cloud scheduler and python
the first step would be writing a python
script which can get the top stories
from the hacker news api
then iterate over every story if any of
their titles match serverless
he'll send you an email with the links
we'll use the request library to make an
http request to the url for the api
which happens to be hosted on firebase a
google cloud product
we'll get all the top stories iterating
over each one
then if any of the stories match we'll
use some custom code to send an email
formatted with all of our serverless
stories
we can put this all in a single python
function we can then deploy this app to
cloud functions
after deploying we get a public url for
our function
cool so whenever i visit this url it
will email me any new articles on the
front page
yep and the last step is running it on a
schedule for this
we used cloud scheduler to create a new
job which runs once a day
cron jobs are scheduled at recurring
intervals specified using the unix cron
format
you can define a schedule so that your
job runs multiple times a day
or runs on specific days and months
we'll schedule our job to run once a day
at midnight
we'll use the gcloud scheduler jobs
create command to create a job which
calls our function on this schedule
we can use gcloud scheduler jobs list to
confirm that our job was created
and we can use gcloud scheduler jobs run
to run it once regardless of the
schedule
oh i got the email this is great i'll
get any serverless articles delivered
right to my inbox every day without me
having to do a thing
thanks of course anything else i can
help you with
actually dustin uh there is one thing
i'm often late to meetings
do you think cloud scheduler and python
can fix that too
i don't think i can help you there oh
[Music]
well
[Music]
you